hola buenas noches se trata de primero
de todo un paquete financiero en que se
va a prohibir el acceso al 70% de los
bancos rusos a los mercados europeos
tampoco se podrá acceder las empresas
estatales rusas que estén dedicadas a la
defensa además la élite rusa tampoco
podrá dejar su dinero en estos bancos
europeos sobre el sector energético con
una prohibición a las exportaciones va a
dificultar enormemente por ejemplo que
el petróleo se pueda refinar esto es una
pérdida de más de 20 mil millones de
euros para la economía rusa también se
va a prohibir la venta del equipo
tecnológico del equipo informático de
los componentes básicos por ejemplo para
que para los aviones rusos tres cuartas
partes de los aviones rusos tienen
componentes europeos o canadienses ha
asegurado la presenta la comisión
europea úrsula von der leyen por lo
tanto se asesta un duro golpe a la
economía rusa según aseguran en los
líderes europeos este hemos podido
escuchar también a charles michel el
presidente del consejo europeo hablar de
acogida
que han propuesto exactamente al
respecto
si así es no han dado muchos detalles al
respecto pero sí que es cierto que la
presenta en la comisión europea ha
asegurado que están preparando ya en un
plan para poder acoger a los refugiados
que entren pues muy probablemente por la
frontera con polonia de hecho ya está
ocurriendo en estos momentos por lo
tanto se trata sobre todo de poder
acoger el máximo de personas posible
dentro de la unión europea y poder
ofrecer ayuda humanitaria a los países
pero son detalles que se van a poder y
se van a poder conocer en los próximos
días